[Music]
on this Sunday night poignant
processions for Canada's fallen officers
the annual memorial for police killed in
the line of duty it's very timely that
we're here this weekend as the suspect
in last week's deadly shooting of a BC
Mountain faces first degree murder
fatal building collapse it's really sad
that you know saying that we have to go
through these things residents in a
Montreal neighborhood shaken plus why
they blame building neglect
Exodus into Armenia
tens of thousands of refugees flee
following a deadly military offensive in
nagorno-karabakh
mission complete a journey of a billion
miles to asteroid bennu and back has
come to an end NASA's Space Capsule
carrying asteroid samples lands on Earth
global national with foreign reporting
tonight
gotcha good evening and thanks for
joining us the risks this country's
police officers face are once again in
Focus today as a BC Community Mourns an
RCMP officer shot and killed last week
flowers candles and messages of
condolence have been piling up at the
Ridge Meadows RCMP station honoring the
memory of constable Rick O'Brien killed
in the line of duty the 51 year old
officer and seven-year veteran of the
force was fatally gunned down while
searching a home in Coquitlam BC the
suspect 25-year-old Nicholas Belmar
remains in custody and has been charged
with first-degree murder and attempted
murder O'Brien is the 10th Canadian
police officer killed on duty by
violence over the last 12 months and
with somber ceremonies across Canada
paying tribute to officers who have
fallen it's another Stark reminder of
their grave sacrifice Mike drolet has
our top story tonight
there's no stoicism at a memorial
flowers are dropped off and in that
moment of silence that follows you hold
your loved ones a little bit closer are
you just a wonderful guy
Steve Ball remembered his friend Rick
O'Brien as a champion for at-risk youth
who dreamed of marrying his two passions
together being an officer and working
with kids and I think he would have made
a wonderful liaison officer I think he
he would have done a fantastic job
I wish he had gotten that chance
dreams It Came Crashing to a halt in a
chaotic scene in coquitlan BC on Friday
O'Brien was on a team executing a search
warrant as part of a drug investigation
police say the suspect opened fire
killing O'Brien and wounding two other
officers one officer was seen leaving
the scene with a tourniquet around his
leg while a bloodied suspect in boxer
shorts was put in an ambulance 25 year
old Nicholas Belmar has been charged
with first-degree murder Nick's gonna
actually talk for me because
I'll introduce them this is Constable
Rick O'Brien with the Ridge Meadows RCMP
Detachment even though O'Brien didn't
join the RCMP until he was 44 he and his
wife Nicole Longacre parents to six
children were active in community
outreach visiting schools and speaking
at the 2020 gratitude and appreciation
Summit because I think what a lot of the
people don't generally
they could kind of almost take it for
granted that these guys are out and
ladies are out there serving and
protecting the community and not
realizing what they're sacrificing their
families are sacrificing to do so
those sacrifices were on full display in
cities across the country as part of the
National Police and Peace Officers
Memorial held every year on the last
Sunday of September the recency of
O'Brien's death made the day that much
harder we're all grieving and it is a
very fresh
experience for all of us and to be able
to come together today and reflect on
that loss I think is very very healing
[Music]
on this day police especially those that
knew Rick O'Brien needed it microlight
Global News
to breaking news now Jewish advocacy
groups are outraged after a man who
fought for a Nazi unit during World War
II was honored in the House of Commons
during Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski's visit to Ottawa on Friday
MPS gave 98-year-old yaroslav hunka a
standing ovation he was introduced by
Speaker Anthony Rota as a war hero who
fought for the first Ukrainian division
the division was also a voluntary unit
that was under the command of the Nazis
in a statement issued Sunday the friends
of Simon wiesenthal Center said it was
deeply Disturbed hunka was invited and
an apology is owed to all Holocaust
Survivors speaker Rota says no one
including fellow parliamentarians and
the Ukrainian delegation was aware of
his intention or remarks beforehand Rota
says he regrets the decision and
apologizes to Jewish communities in
Canada and around the world and he
accepts full responsibility for his
actions the prime minister's office says
no advance notice was provided to them
or the Ukrainian delegation about this
adding the speaker had his own allotment
of guests which were determined by him
and his office alone conservative party
leader Pierre pauliev described it as an
appalling error in judgment and is
calling for the prime minister to
apologize saying his protocol office is
responsible for vetting all guests for
State visits like this
officials are trying to figure out what
led to a deadly building collapse in
Montreal Saturday one man was killed and
two others were severely injured
multiple investigations are underway as
Dan Spector reports all signs point to a
renovation project turning into a
tragedy
butcher Andre Bo Dwayne was at work
around four o'clock Saturday afternoon
when he heard a massive boom boom
it was like an earthquake he says but
Dwayne went outside the shop he manages
to find a chaotic scene part of this
building had collapsed and people were
stuck inside Witnesses described screams
heard from inside the broken structure
firefighters and paramedics arrived soon
after and evacuated the mixed
residential commercial building first of
all they have to deal with the Panic
around the scene so they would have to
be sure that the security the scene is
secure a look through a small hole in
the door clearly shows part of the floor
on the main level gave way a man who was
underneath was killed two more people
were transported to hospital with
serious injuries and another two had
minor injuries all the victims in their
30s or 40s it took hours for
firefighters to reach the man who lost
his life we had to really secure the
site so we installed polls in the in the
basement to make sure it was safe enough
the side of the building where the
collapse happened had been abandoned
since a fire two years ago the Quebec's
workplace safety board the CNE SST tells
Global News the disaster took place
during construction work inside odway
and others said they'd seen men working
this side of the building was deemed
safe by an engineer and workers and
residents were allowed back in but the
community is still stunned by the
violent tragedy really terrible to hear
distressing it's really sad that you
understand that we have to go through
these things police say they are
offering their support to investigations
being done by the coroner's office and
the CNE SST but Dwayne said he saw the
workers removing wood and blocks from
the building he wonders if the collapse
was caused by human error
Quebec's workplace health and safety
board says the investigation could last
several months as they interview
Witnesses and try to piece together what
happened Dan Specter Global News
Montreal
now to the mass Exodus from
nagorno-karabakh a mostly ethnic
Armenian Enclave inside Azerbaijan about
120 000 ethnic Armenians are expected to
flee after Azerbaijan effectively took
control of the disputed region by force
resulting in 200 deaths hundreds of
people have already crossed into Armenia
as Redmond Shannon reports Armenians
around the world including in Canada are
calling for help to ensure the safety of
those deciding to stay
hundreds of ethnic Armenians arrive in
Armenia escorted there by Russian
peacekeepers days after fleeing their
homes in nagorno-karabakh
this man said in the last few days we
barely survived the shelling it was
scary on Tuesday azerbaijani forces
moved to take full control of the mostly
ethnic Armenian region forcing many of
the 120 000 residents from their homes
200 people died before Wednesday's
ceasefire some of them civilians
nagorno-karabakh is an enclave inside
the territory of Azerbaijan but
controlled for decades by ethnic
Armenians since a war in 2020 its only
land connection to Armenia was a
corridor patrolled by Russian
peacekeepers in recent months Azerbaijan
blockaded that Corridor leading two
shortages of food Fuel and medicines a
press valued to azerbaijan's military
offensive
armenia's prime minister says
evacuations to his country may be the
only way to ensure the safety of
residents at the U.N his foreign
minister appealed for help to prevent
what he called the risk of genocide a
sustainable and viable International
mechanism for preventing the ethnic
cleansing of the indigenous population
of nagorna karabakh foreign
Canadians gathered in Toronto Sunday
expressing similar concerns among them
filmmaker Adam ugoyan this is destroying
an essential part of our heritage an
essential part of our of our culture and
our identity the azeri government has
dismissed concerns of ethnic cleansing
is determined to reintegrate ethnic
Armenian residents of the god of region
of Azerbaijan as equal citizens the
conflict has its roots in the chaos of
the end of the Soviet Union when
thousands of azeries and Armenians were
killed and hundreds of thousands
displaced
this evacuee says it's her third time
being forced from nagorno-karabakh right
now no one knows if she'll return again
and what might happen to those who
remain Redmond Shannon Global News
London
best and final offer coming up the
potential breakthrough in the Hollywood
writer strike
in Hollywood there's significant
progress in negotiations between big
Studio bosses and the union representing
film and television writers on strike
after months of job action there are
signs both sides may be on the cusp of a
deal that doesn't automatically mean
Productions can resume though and with
actors still on strike disruptions are
far from over Brittany Rosen explains
it's been 146 days since Hollywood film
writers have been on the picket lines
but that could soon change with a deal
reportedly on the horizon there's
optimism There's Hope but nothing's real
until the inks drive on the contracts a
positive signal towards the end of a
month's long dispute the major film and
television Studios delivered their best
and final offer to writer Saturday
evening and both sides met again Sunday
the eve of Jewish holiday Yom Kippur
there seems to have been an informal
deadline of wanting to get a deal done
if possible before Yom Kippur it comes
as the strike inches closer to
surpassing the longest work stoppage in
Union history at 154 days writers and
say after actors who join the strike in
mid-july have been fighting for a number
of overlapping demands including higher
wages and worker protections including
the use of artificial intelligence we're
willing to go as long as we need to get
this done once a deal is reached it
needs to be ratified which experts say
could take two to three weeks while
Riders would pick off where they left
off it doesn't mean filming will be
taken off pause you can't make anything
with that actors so nothing is going to
be resolved until the actors get a deal
and when actors eventually negotiate
their contract industry experts say
there will be all sorts of booking
conflicts due to the strike we're not
going to see production at sort of
normal smooth running mode and levels
until you know January with each day
that passes more money and jobs are
being lost experts say the economic
impact of writers and actors strikes
have surpassed a stake a ring 5 billion
dollars it's had a ripple effect for the
Canadian economy and is being
increasingly felt among numerous
Industries even when things end they're
going to find that it's very difficult
to crawl out from under the mess that's
been made over the last couple of months
and ramping up production during a
forecasted recession Lander says will
only add to those challenges Brittany
Rose in Global News Washington
uniforce says it's 5600 workers at Ford
have voted to accept a three-year deal
with the automaker the union says the
agreement addresses all issues raised by
members during the latest round of
bargaining including wages pension and
job security amid the transition to
electric vehicle manufacturing uniforce
says it will use the new agreement as a
pattern for negotiations with General
Motors and stellantis and will announce
which of those companies is the next
Target in the near future
[Music]
ahead one of the world's top music video
directors on breaking down barriers to
racial Justice
from Drake to Rihanna and Nicki Minaj
Director X has filmed more than 100
music videos he's also built an
impressive resume in film and television
including his latest project a take on
Robin Hood
[Music]
the show which will air on global and
Stat TV has a female Robin Hood and a
cast of black protagonists our Farah
Nasser sat down with Director X to talk
about the need for more diversity in the
industry
and how did a kid from Brampton Ontario
get to this level
um persistence
luck
you know a lot of things converge
together and a lot of things can merge
together persistence is a big part of it
was it hard to break into the industry
yeah I had to move to America I had to
leave Canada you couldn't have broken
into the industry in Canada never
what are the biggest barriers right now
that bypoc filmmakers face
there's a part of filmmaking
where getting in is its own mysterious
Journey right you ask a grip and a guy
for and a director and a produce you
never know what they're going to say
right how they made it into the business
so there's just the business it's almost
like Harry Potter like there's a secret
door somewhere and if you can find it
you can say work on a film set there's
that big part of it and then as well
changing the minds of people to see
people see this talent and the skill and
not
a race or a gender or you know you know
what I mean no explain it to me they're
just assuming you couldn't do it because
you're a black guy you're a black kid
let's just assume you can do it because
you're a black woman you assumed you
couldn't do it you know I mean like I
was a given you can't do this you're I
mean that was all the way through you
think that prejudice still exists of
course
I mean you got your super Prejudice like
I don't like
and then you got this the subtle
Prejudice is actually the scarier one
the stories I tell about some person
speaking to me disrespectfully or down
to me or assuming I don't know
what I know I've been in the Canadian
television industry
more than in the states
it doesn't happen in the states so it's
it's interesting that you say that it's
more
more apparent here I mean we come across
as so polite right here in Canada I'm
curious to understand why do you think
you've seen that more here in Canada in
the states there's a long history of
relationships white folks and black
folks and you know I mean how they
interact it's its own thing that isn't
here right and what is here a lot of it
is gleamed off of Americans
entertainment
you know what I mean
so there's just people who haven't had
that experience haven't been around
other folks and just is what it is man
so do you think what do you think the
scene is right now I know when you
started you were saying that like you
know it's hard to break it was hard to
break in and that kind of thing what do
you think it's like right now for black
filmmakers I mean there's definitely a
lot more programs it's all very focused
on directors and writers and producers
I'd love to see programs for the crew
and train you to be a grip train you to
be a guy for train you to be aesthetic
train you have to be a production
designer train you how to do hair makeup
train you right there's a lot of jobs
a lot of things going on on a film set
not everything has to be in the big
chair
that I love going to a job and that's in
America the last job I did all these all
the electrics are black all the Gaffers
are black
it's a big deal
and here it's not like that in general
for a city that one of our Industries is
filmmaking we should be training
filmmakers on those nuts and bolts how
do you feel about how the industry has
evolved in the years that you've been
doing this
good man
slow slow moving but good to see some
color in the audience let's go on some
sets and see some you know I mean
turn on the TV like a joke about it but
yeah Robin Hood is a all black Robin
Hood that's a crazy scent it's a crazy
thing but they're doing it there's a lot
to celebrate yeah
all right thank you so much thank you
director X's Robin Hood premieres on
global and stack TV this Wednesday
next asteroid samples dating back to the
birth of the solar system land on Earth
has touched them
it's a moment seven years in the making
for NASA as its first ever asteroid
sample collected from space landed back
on Earth in the Utah desert the space
Rubble could bring us one step closer to
solving Earth's biggest mystery and as
Eric Sorensen explains Canada is getting
a piece of the interstellar treasure
this close-up view you can see the
parachute disconnected there it is for
the first time since 2016 the little
capsule from osiris-rex is back on Earth
Lockheed Martin safety is performing
hazardous environment assessments the
charred 50 kilogram space pod arrived
with cargo that is little more than dust
and grit but for scientists it is 250
grams of Wonder and knowledge
and liftoff of osiris-rex it was an
outrageous mission to send a spacecraft
to an asteroid millions of kilometers
away it took osiris-rex two years to get
to Tiny bennu and another two years to
study the rocky surface to find a place
to touch down and when the moment came a
long arm plunged into the Gravelly
surface gathered about half a pound of
material and sealed it in the capsule
sample collection is complete and the
back away burn has executed
two years after leaving bennu and with a
2 billion kilometer journey home success
was always going to come down to the
final few hours and minutes osiris-rex
jettisoned the sample return capsule
fired thrusters to Veer away from
colliding with Earth and the capsule
then plunged into the atmosphere
at a precise angle so as not to burn up
the tiny capsule finally floated by
Parachute into the Utah desert the
precious cargo intact these samples that
we've brought back those are going to be
a treasure for scientific analysis for
years and years and years to come
because the Earth remakes itself over
eons there are no original rocks here
the carbon samples from bennu pristine
and 4 billion years old could tell us
about our own Origins these are all the
building blocks for Life maybe you can
learn a little bit about you know how
what was happening in the solar system
at that time how did our planet form the
Canadian space agency contributed laser
navigation to osiris-rex and for that
the CSA will receive a few grams of
bennu dust to study the first job is to
ensure the Earth's environment doesn't
pollute the asteroid dust it's very
challenging with some of our analyzes to
protect the sample you know at the level
that we would store it long term as for
Osiris exit missed hitting Earth and
will now Circle the Sun for a few years
before chasing down another asteroid
that's expected to fly very close to
Earth in 2029. Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm nitu Garcia tonight's
your Canada is Halifax Nova Scotia have
a great night
[Music]